alors françois legault qui donnait
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'entrevues avec plusieurs médias qui
fait son bilan mais en fait ce n'est pas
une entrevue classique de fin d'année
puisqu'on est en plein chaos vide alors
un sujet qui ont marqué notre rencontre
on s'est rencontrés ce matin au palais
des congrès à montréal les commerces
bien sûr vous allez l'entente on doit
resserrer la vis quand exactement c'est
annoncer demain
pas question vous allez voir y'a pas
changé d'idée sur une commission
publique d'enquêté sur le fiasco des
sièges celle des les transferts fédéraux
c'est intéressant vous allez voir ce
qu'il a à dire sur l'élection fédérale
carrie alors on écoute sort et on
revient ensuite sur le premier ministre
bonjour bonjour ne se voit vous allez
devoir resserrer la vis là demain vous
l'annoncer est-ce que les commerces on
doit s'attendre qu'on doive fermière
pourquoi deux trois semaines au moins
côté vous avez vu madame merkel en fin
de semaine faire des annonces en trop
bien pour les magasins moi je me suis
beaucoup inspiré de madame merkel depuis
le début de la pandémie au mois de mars
parce que dit on pas que c'est
l'allemagne s'en est mieux tiré peu près
dans le monde entier donc on va annoncer
ça demain après midi mais effectivement
va falloir resserrer la situation dans
les commerces donc offrir est fermée
pour une certaine partie parce que il ya
trop de contacts faut réduire les
contacts puis déjà il ya beaucoup dans
votre ferme et de la construction est
fermée pour deux semaines les
entreprises au moins pour une semaine
les écoles pour deux semaines donc il
reste les commerces là faut donner un
grand coup dans le temps des fêtes est
ce que ça pour agir au delà du 4 5
janvier comme les écoles fermées
jusqu'au 10
on met là on va annoncer ça dans mes
mains mais est ce qu'on veut c'est de
laisser des gens faire le magasinage
pour leurs enfants
mais par la suite là il faut donner un
coup vous dites faut donner un coup
qu'est ce qui vous inquiète le plus
c'est vraiment les hospitalisations
parce que l'on sent que le réseau là il
ya certains hôpitaux que ça c'est pas
loin de 40 et dimanche à 880
hospitalisation ça c'est 8 180 lits
occupés par des patients colline d'élite
peuvent pas être occupés par des
patients qui ont d'autres problèmes qui
ont d'autres traitements à voir donc
c'est vraiment ce qui est le plus
inquiétant le plus critique ce nombre
d'hospitalisations est ce que l'on vous
donne un chiffre au ministère de la
santé en détention sont arrivés mais
l'hospitalisation monsieur le premier
ministre
ça va être comme la première règle
tellement délestage
il ya du monde qui vont sans exagérer
mourir là d'autres maladies c'est pas un
chiffre global parce qu'il faut le
regarder région par région faut garder
le montréal pour garder 4 5 0
bon là il ya certaines régions comme le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean qui sont très
affectés donc faut presque à garder sa
hôpital par hôpital dans nord des
laurentides à saint-girons il n'y avait
pas trop de problèmes jusqu'à une
semaine ou deux mais là c'est en train
d'augmenter donc il faut le regarder
hôpital par l'hôpital
les vaccins
sont à voile et le kaiser dans un siège
celle des quotidiens luc un à québec
et l'on apprend aux seiches et celles
dites côte saint luc à 60% du personnel
qui dit moi je vais pas me faire
vacciner tout de suite
est ce que vous allez vous faire
vacciner plus vite bientôt en public
avez vous une stratégie pour enlever ou
apaiser les craintes des gens qui
veulent pas se faire vacciner
d'abord moi je vais me faire vacciner
mais à quel moment ça serait la santé
publique décide rôle dans l'ordre de
priorité quand c'est le temps du premier
ministre mme actuellement notre priorité
il serait actuellement à 70% des décès
qui sont dans les chu celle des plaies
rhdp a donc on a besoin de quelques
centaines de milliers de vaccins pour
vacciner tous les résidents puis le
personnel des cfc le dip des meilleurs
techniquement une fois que c'est fait on
vient d'éliminer soixante dix pour cent
des décès donc ça va changer
portrait complètement maintenant il ya
tout le personnel de la santé dans
l'ensemble des hôpitaux du réseau qui va
aussi et en priorité
moi je m'attends pas à ce que beaucoup
de gens qui refusent le vaccin
actuellement tous les pays ont accepté
le vaccin est donc c'était vérifié
contre-vérifier par à peu près tous les
pays mais j'ai été étonné d'entendre
cette statistique la somme atteint 60%
du personnel vous trouvez ça et nous
espérons que ce soit peut-être pas ça ou
que ça change mais est-ce que vous allez
vous allez en public est ce que vous
allez faire une démonstration au moment
où on choisira moi je veux pas passer
dans personne d'autre donc c'est la
santé publique qui va décider du moment
vont probablement aujourd'hui qu'on va
montrer certains résidents résidente qui
se font vacciner les gens un peu moins
peur parce que c'est un vaccin comme
pour la grippe player rien de dramatique
écoutez c'est enfin savoir la colite que
tu es plus 5000 personnes
vous avez jamais eu peur de la voir
parce que vous dites moi je veux pas
passer devant en même temps vous êtes
premier ministre si vous avez un rôle
essentiel dans cette crise là ce serait
peut-être bien de ton billet promenade
ouais je suis prudent donc je me tiens
toujours à deux mètres de tout le monde
quand j'étais à l'intérieur je porte un
masque sauf pour les entrevues ou soit
sauf pour les points de presse donc je
suis prudent ça ne soit rejetée aller
chez ma mère parce qu'elle vit seul
juste aller seul pour nous porter chacun
un masque pour ne reste à 2 m donc je
toujours prudent mais vous avez vous
n'êtes pas un soir vous êtes pas dit à
votre femme par exemple j'ai peur de la
voir si je les caisses qui arrive
comment va faire est-ce que vos yeux
cette crainte là de tomber mal à souhait
de la commune soit d'épuisement soit
fatigue ça commençait à faire longtemps
non je suis en bonne santé moi je fais
quand même beaucoup de support entre
autres l'elliptique et puis bon je suis
en bonne forme donc je tape on est
inquiet de ma santé
la coved il ya une épisode un épisode là
quand j'ai rencontré monsieur o'toole
donc mais j'avais été prudent j'ai
regardé le manceau pour une petite
entrevue quelques minutes
et puis je te lis mfa tester et donc
j'ai essayé ça d'avoir sa d'emmener le
plu à tout le monde pendant quelques
secondes c'est pas agréable mais ça
devrait y quelques secondes bon parlons
de choses pas agréable monsieur legault
chez vous avez répondu déjà ne vous en
vouliez pas d' enquête publique mais je
vais revenir parce que je comprends pas
pourquoi vous voyez l'ehpad enquête
publique
il n'y a pas quatre mille bonnes raisons
de tenir une enquête publique 4000 morts
ces peaux claires à l'époque pour qu'on
a tous mis dans les hôpitaux pippa dans
les chsld qui a pris la décision si tu
vous c'est une ministère de la santé
sexuelle à la santé publique
est-ce que compte tenu de l'ampleur du
problème auquel on a dû faire face à ça
devrait pas être une vraie commission
denquête piqué d'abord ce qui est
important d'ici à trois ans qu'est qui
sont en cours devant lui l enquête la
commissaire à la santé
johan castonguay qui l'a fait de de
claude castonguay qui connaît bien le
réseau qui lui disent toutes ses
coutures depuis 15 ans d'autres
l'âge et puis oubliée au port c'est un
poste qui avait aboli comme sert à la
santé qu'on a créé notre gouvernement
appuie le choix de la personne est
appuyé par les quatre partis c'est sa
première chaud deuxièmement une
protectrice du citoyen qui a déposé son
rapport préliminaire la première étape
la semaine dernière puis qui poursuit
son travail qui nous sommes sur le go
contredit sur la sphère de l'équipement
dont on pourrait on pourrait revenir ont
pu revenir tout de suite mais j'ai juste
dit il ya des enquêtes criminelles aussi
dans certains chu celle des le laval et
ron est tout seul puis moi ce que je
voulais surtout c'est d'avoir des
réponses rapides donc même question qui
travaillent très fort depuis un certain
nombre de mois
pam premier set 6 maximum le mois de
septembre d'année prochaine
parce que pour moi ce qui est important
c'est de 10 et des choses à corriger
ben il faut les clubs et jugés
maintenant puisqu'il rapport de la
protectrice du citoyen elle nous a dit
essentiellement deux choses qui sont
soit corrigée ou entre un et deux kg 1
l'équipement de protection non moi je
suis vaisseau au jour le jour ne jamais
manquer d'équipements de protection je
le mets mais dans les minutes
jégo et non non non jamais tant les
menus j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'ils pouvaient en avoir manqué qui en
a manqué dans certains chu c'est le dip
savez vous pourquoi parce que il n'y
avait pas de responsable l'ancien
gouvernement a enlevé les directeurs
généraux des chu celle des dons qu'il
n'y avait pas de personne qui disait
moche imputable un vérifier dans
l'inventaire à chaque jour de s'assurer
que tous les employés portent hockey
league
ma part je sais que les gens qu'on
pourrait elle l'a dit parce qu'elle a
fait beaucoup d'entrevues 48% des
travailleuses et travailleurs de la
santé ont rapporté avoir manquer
d'équipements de protection
ça c'est du vrai manque ont manqué de
vraiment actuellement devrait blues
ouais mais mais quand je marque oui bon
matin quand je regarde à chaque jour
l'inventaire on avait pour des semaines
puis quand un ch c'est de nous demander
de l'équipement était de livrer la
journée même
la journée même donc on ne jamais
manquer d'équipements au total
mais il ya des 6h à cela des employés
qu'un homme en wallonie bon vieux des
chs elle dit qu'on peut lever la main
posée et moi je vais à manquer d'accord
pierre des chs elle dit aussi qu'ils ont
dit à leurs employés aux pas nécessaire
de porter un masque dont toutes les
procédures de prévention était pape qui
parce qu'elle aussi a eu des postes de
couper dans vos enquêtes là que ce soit
mais nous restons guillot donc qui va
venir vous voir vous pour vous demander
telle date au mois de mars pour qu on a
tout mis des hôpitaux qui passait dans
les chaussettes dès qu'ils vont être
capables de vous regarder dans les yeux
puis vous demandez ça moi je pense que
même question gay capable de faire la
préfecture le drouais noyer à d'autre
avant de poser toutes les questions
nécessaires
mais si vous revenez sur la question des
hôpitaux je regarde aujourd'hui ce qui
est le plus critique ce sont les 880
personnes qui sont hospitalisées
parce que seul ça bloque tout le reste
du réseau
donc il faut se préparer oui dans les
csss elle dit mais aussi dans les
hôpitaux
quand je vous dis tantôt mode ans et
siège à celle des avec la vaccination
problème doit être réglé dans les
prochaines semaines mais les hôpitaux
mais là ça met des délais ce haut que
les opérations c'est grave pour boucler
la boucle du passé vous dire on n'a pas
besoin
vous êtes soumis ne pas avoir besoin
d'un exercice que beaucoup de juges
serait salutaire pour faire le point sur
chaque détail des décisions publiques ça
déjà lieu à moins que quelqu'un qui est
pas personne même dans les oppositions
qui me dit je n'ai pas confiance à
madame castonguay madame castonguay
allemand doc très large de regarder
poser des questions par tous la
protectrice du citoyen aussi il ya des
beaucoup de gens qui souffrent depuis le
début de cette crise monsieur vous vous
êtes le premier à savoir les jeunes ya
un jeune qui vous a écrit une lettre
publique dans les journaux entretien du
buteur félix béret remaniant qui vous a
dit moi je suis devant mon écran depuis
neuf mois j'ai plus de contact est ce
que pour les jeunes du cégep et
l'université
a pas moyen de faire un paul je
comprends c'est un équilibre difficile
mais de faire un pas pour les sortir de
leur bulle
oui absolument puis c'est quelque chose
que je discute avec la santé publique
depuis des mois des semaines que je
reviens à la charge
parce que si on prend le primat puis
seconde 1 97 % des enfants sont à
l'école mais au cégep à l'université
c'est ce sont des co à distance puis les
jeunes côté on se souvient quand on
avait vingt et un ont besoin de voir
d'autre part je suis des coûts en
présence de leurs profs mais voit
d'autres jeunes donc lorsqu'on est un
leurre regarder avec daniel mais cannes
c'est qu' au moins un pourcentage de 10
bon ok si vous dites on peut pas être
plus que 15 dans une classe mettons en
et puis les autres seront à la maison
matteau de rôles faudrait qu'ils
viennent dans les cégeps et les
universités parce qu'on est les ou
malades mais quand l'impression que
c'est pas pris au sérieux ce feu là chez
les jeunes vous écoutez le partout dans
le monde ont dit nous il faut faire le
plus attention ça dans les
établissements d'enseignement sa vie
écoles cégeps universités c'est là qu'il
ya le plus d'éclosion et dans les
entreprises
donc évidemment on fait pas exprès pour
empirer le problème là ouais mais c'est
une balance de ce n'est que les banques
la santé sauver des vies la santé
mentale des purificateurs d'air c'est
pas compliqué on est soudain écoles les
parents mais crient pas tous les jours
qu'on prenne pas vous répondre
écoutez moi je pose la question à toutes
les semaines depuis des mois et la santé
publique pm10 n'y a pas personne que
prouver que les dans les classes des
écoles que là est un facteur important
de transmission une 10 il ya des études
qui disent ça pourrait amener une
contagion meilleurs y est qu'ils peuvent
parce que les jeunes qui ont été
contaminées où on a fermé des classes
d'abord la plupart ont été contaminés à
l'extérieur de l'école les autres c'est
souvent dans le corridor en étant trop
proche des aux enfants mais il
ça parce que c'est ce que me dit la
santé publique que prouver que la
qualité de l'air avait un impact
significatif sur la transmission
donc moi je me fie à la santé publique
ouais mais par précaution des
purificateurs d'eau ça peut pas faire de
mal
ça peut pas faire de mal je suis
d'accord mais il faut d'abord faire
l'entretien des systèmes de ventilation
c'est plus important que met des
purificateurs les purificateurs faudra
en mettre plus bas le jeu comprend qu'il
ya des commissions scolaires anglophones
qui ont décidé que c'était même si elle
n'est pas une recommandation de la santé
publique ils l'ont fait pareil mais là
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'elle que je
vous dise là une question d'argent
ce qu'on n'a pas l'argent peut acheter
ça il ya un budget de près un milliard
et demi par année d'entretien mais
l'entretien des écoles ça inclut la
ventilation
mais est ce que c'est une priorité de
mettre les purificateurs d'air selon la
santé publique
la réponse est non est-ce que vous
pouvez désormais être plus clair si vos
décisions
c'est une recommandation de la santé
publique ou sur décision politique parce
que l'on navigue entre deux pôles
d'affaires des restaurants la semaine
dernière qu'ils sortent le dr hamda puis
vous dire on pourrait les laisser
ouverts pour les cellules familiales
vous avez dit j'ai pris la décision
politique mais c'est pas clair est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un processus où ça va
être plus clair d'abord le principe de
base la santé publique fait des
recommandations
puis nos gouvernements on décide seul le
principe c'est moi qui étais lui donc
c'est moi qui décide quand la santé
publique nous a dit faudrait fermer les
écoles des entreprises d'ici une semaine
moi j'ai dit ça va être demain matin
donc j'allais plus loin
quand l'avez dit vous l'avez dit c'est
fallait quand la santé publique a dit
bon c'est peut-être pas nécessaire de
fermer les restaurants moi j'ai dit
écoutez je pense qu'il faut les fermer
moi je regardais ce qui se fait ailleurs
puis aujourd'hui presque partout les
noms les restaurants sont fermés
quand on a donné deux congés noël
monsieur à loudon faisait on va attendre
une semaine pour voir l'évolution j'ai
dit non
non là c'est trop élevé on annule tout
de suite donc ce que j'ai dit depuis le
début de la pandémie
c'est que je toujours été aussi prudents
ou plus prudent que la santé publique
mais en bout de ligne c'est moi qui est
au bat là c'est moi qui prends la
décision
puis j'ai toujours été plus loin que ce
que me disait la santé publique
pourquoi vous séparez pas comme dans
plusieurs autres pays vous a parlé de
l'allemagne talent à votre modèle la
santé publique qu'il fasse ses
conférences de presse de son côté
michelle rodda puis vous faites vos
conférences de presse de l'eau cette
proximité là depuis le début c'est
peut-être ce qui crée une confusion ans
pour moi je pense au contraire que si il
ya deux messages puis en plus ça évolue
beaucoup les messages change presse à
chaque semaine donc c'est mieux d'avoir
un message commun qui en pratique ce qui
arrive c'est que la santé publique nous
dit ben moi je ferais sauce aux sons
d'autres ont dit oui
est ce que si on ferait plutôt so so so
n'arrivera pas au même objectif
c'est un échange c'est pas une
hypocrisie là avez-vous totalement
confiance encore à votre directeur de
santé publique de cela va totalement ce
quelqu'un compétences que je crois qu'on
peut te lire depuis des semaines et des
semaines et des semaines qui brouillon
qu'il ya de la meuse à s'exprimer ça me
dérange pas comme premier ministre mme
patron a écouté le lit est en train
d'apprendre la communication politique
c'est qu'à un moment donné faut
communiquer un message clair puis moi le
premier on a toujours à s'améliorer pour
être plus clair faut faire des réponses
courtes et puis ok je vais poser des
questions claires l'argent d'ottawa y
arrive rapport demain ni après-demain la
cclat monsieur trudeau a dit non pour
l'instant
j'étais choquée la semaine dernière mais
votre budget il est arrivé en fonction
de l'entrée d'argent du fédéral
soyons clair monsieur legault ce que ça
veut dire des hausses d'impôts ou des
coupures de service je n'arriverai pas à
boucler
selon vos prévisions ça dépend combien
d'années ont fait les prévisions et vous
avez raison
lors cette année le déficit est plus
gros a town dans les provinces mais la
grosse partie du déficit à tahoua ce
sont des dépenses non récurrents
donc quand on fait une projection sur
dix ans on voit que ta voix va réussir à
équilibrer son budget mais matin des
surplus alors que les provinces vont
rester en déficit structurel pour deux
raisons parce que les dépenses en santé
augmentent plus vite que les revenus qu
on en as une soixante dix huit pour cent
dans les provinces
deuxième raison à cause du mix des
impôts une croissance plus rapide des
revenus à ottawa que dans les provinces
mais vous ne donne pas monsieur le
vouloir pour les mais voilà ça je
comprends vous plaît 10 si vous le même
poste que vous avez tous obligés
d'augmenter impôts de baisser services à
savoir monsieur trudeau a dit moi je
trouvais à augmenter le financement mais
je voudrais l'augmenter dans deux
secteurs avec mes conditions
donc je voudrais moi met des normes dans
les chs ld puis je voudrais avoir une
assurance médicaments à grandeur du
canada alors que nous au québec on note
des jeux réassurance médicaments donc
ils disent pas qui veut pas mettre
d'argent
il dit que plutôt que de naître des
transferts en santé il voudrait
intervenez dans des champs de compétence
des provinces soit sa première chose
deuxièmement monsieur otto chef de
police officielle dit moi je serais prêt
à augmenter les transferts sans
condition on sait qu'on a un
gouvernement minoritaire et vous donnera
également une élection fédérale et vous
travaillez monsieur legault donc à faire
battre monsieur trudeau lors de la
prochaine élection côté on va voir
d'abord quand même ce trou d'eau va
évoluer mais est ce que c'est une option
pour vous de dire ça se peut que je met
mon propos politique derrière monsieur
où tous les conservateurs ben écoutez il
ya pas juste moi non mais y'a d'oxford
violée non mais ça joue beaucoup au
québec en ontario des élections
fédérales donc c'est pour ça que je
m'assure d'être très proche d'oxford
le dogue faut des mois on entend des
transferts importants sans condition
donc je vois comment ça évolue comme un
monsieur trudeau évolue comme un
monsieur o'toole évolué
john horgan vient du npd parle avec
monsieur sinon palais que le bloc
québécois
il ya une dynamique qui va s'opérer d'un
prochain monde y est pas impossible que
vous mettiez votre poids politique des
m le chef conservateur lors de la
prochaine campagne fédérale
c'est certain que les québécois pour les
québécois c'est important la santé donc
si un parti fédéral dit moi je vois
mettre plus d'argent santé je pense ça
va l'aider mais bloque hébron au sol si
vous voulez aider les conservateurs j'ai
pas dit que j'aiderai où l'ont d'abord
il ya beaucoup de sujets nous aurons une
campagne électorale donc différents
partis qui vont différentes positions
sur les différents dossiers et mais aux
québécois si le chèque n'arrive pas
parce que l'on parle dans plusieurs
plusieurs plusieurs mois vous aviez
quand même escompter une augmentation du
transfert pas mal est ce qu'il risque
d'avoir des périodes où vous resserrez
les services ou monter les impôts
non ce qu'on voit dans le budget c'est
que cette année et un déficit de 15
milliards à partir de l'année prochaine
et un déficit de 6 7 milliards
récurrents ok le nous la question qui se
pose c'est de dire bon sur combien
d'années on veut rétablir l'équité
budgétaire il ya deux procédures n'avons
pas de série t il n'y aurait pas d'
austérité d'abord il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation des impôts des taxes
puis repas de coupures dans les dépenses
de santé d'éducation dans les dépenses
du gouvernement du québec
alors malgré le contexte difficile
monsieur le premier je vous souhaite de
joyeuses fêtes à vous à votre famille à
votre mère dont vous parlez souvent dans
ses conférences de presse ne faut pas
oublier nos parents qui sont seuls
effectivement la maison alors on se voit
ceux reçus on veut se reparler de
racisme puis une autre fois d autres
sujets de la langue française merci
beaucoup je veux en profiter moi aussi
tous vos auditeurs ont souhaité un bon
temps d'éveil d'être prudent il reste
quelques mois on voit la lumière au bout
du tunnel mais il ya encore des mois
difficiles devant nous malheureusement
voyait arriver ensemble
merci monsieur merci monsieur roy pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne
6h10
[Musique]